thank you for your incredibly warm
welcome certainly to my delegation and
our colleagues from the uk media as well
um i'm delighted to be here in kigali
alongside our friend and partner
minister dr vincent brucha and i just
would like to express my personal thanks
in particular to him and his team for
the constructive way in which we have
been working
over many many months to achieve and
deliver this partnership
the united kingdom has a long and proud
development history with rwanda and our
shared interests have resulted in a
strong and strong economic and
development growth lifting millions out
of poverty but also resulting in growing
manufacturing and technology sectors
which are generating jobs and
sustainable
growth for generations to come
now i know firsthand that your country
minister is a regional and international
leader you are on the global stage very
much yourself more often than not but
also hosting the commonwealth heads of
government meeting the world
telecommunications development
conference and the sustainable energy
for all forum your national leadership
is the african voice on international
initiatives which really speaks to
seeking to find solutions through
regional and international challenges
and i'm very honored to be here and the
uk is delighted to be working ever more
closely with rwanda
we have many many interests in common
and we face many of the same challenges
and i want to turn to one of those
challenges now
the global migration crisis and how we
tackle illegal migration requires new
world leading solutions there are an
estimated 80 million people displaced in
the world and the global approach to
asylum and migration is broken
evil people smugglers and their criminal
gangs are facilitating people into
europe resulting in the loss of life and
shoe costs to the uk taxpayer
the tragic loss of life of people in the
channel and in the mediterranean at the
hands of these evil people smugglers
must stop
and today our approach is to
outward-looking countries has led to the
signing of a new international
partnership which is a world first it is
a migration and economic development
partnership with the country of rwanda
and the uk
this will see some of those arriving
illegally in the uk such as those
crossing the channel in dangerous small
boats relocated to rwanda to resettle
and to rebuild their lives in the way in
which the ministers just outline
more than 28 000 migrants crossed the
channel last year by a small boat in
very dangerous and perilous conditions
the uk asylum system is collapsing under
a combination of real humanitarian
crises and evil people smugglers
profiteering by exploiting the system
for their own gains
criminals are exploiting the hopes and
fears of migrants pushing them to making
dangerous journeys to the uk with
fictitious and false promises that they
can settle in the uk if they make it
and this has devastating consequences
for the countless men women and children
who have tragically lost their lives or
loved ones on perilous journeys
it is also deeply unfair because it
advantages those with the means to pay
smugglers over the vulnerable who cannot
global systems and conventions have
failed to address this global crisis
and the world has changed and renewed
global leadership is required to find
new innovative solutions to this growing
problem
today the united kingdom and rwanda have
signed a joint new migration and
economic development partnership to put
an end to this deadly trade in people
smuggling
this is part of the united kingdom's new
plan for immigration to control our
borders protect our communities stop
dangerous illegal migration help the
world's most desperate people and
welcome international talents to the uk
it is the biggest overhaul of our
immigration system in decades
underpinned by a nationality and borders
bill which will soon become law
our country the united kingdom has
always extended the hand of friendship
to those in need in recent years alone
we have proudly welcomed tens of
thousands of refugees from syria
afghanistan ukraine and bno's from hong
kong
rwanda has one of the strongest records
for refugee resettlement and in recent
years as the minister has just
said rwanda has resettled over 130 000
refugees
it has an established record of
welcoming and integrating people such as
those from the democratic republic of
congo and burundi
but also
including for example people from libya
evacuate evacuated under the eu's
emergency transit mechanism in
partnership with the um refugee agency
and the african union rwanda is also a
state party to the 1951 u.n refugee
convention and the seven core principles
of the un human rights convention
border control is fundamental to
national sovereignty
uncontrolled immigration reduces our
capability and capacity to help those
who need our support it puts intolerable
pressures on public services and on
local communities and at home as the
prime minister has said today because
the capacity of the asylum system is not
unlimited the presence of economic
migrants
which these illegal roots introduce into
the asylum system inhibits our ability
to support others in genuine need of
protection
the british people are fair and generous
when it comes to helping those in need
but the persistent circumventing of our
laws and immigration rules and the
reality of a system that is open to
gaming and criminal exploitation has
eroded public support for britain's
asylum system and those that genuinely
need access to it putting evil people
smugglers out of business is a moral
imperative
it requires us to use every tool at our
disposal and also to find new solutions
that is why today's migration and
economic development partnership with
rwanda is a major milestone
it is also very much in keeping with our
vision for global britain that harnesses
the potential for new relationships and
stimulates investments and jobs in
partner countries
working together
the united kingdom and rwanda will help
make the immigration system far
better ensure that people are safe and
enjoy new opportunities to flourish
we have agreed that people who enter the
uk illegally will be considered for
relocation to rwanda to have their
asylum systems their asylum claims
decided
and those who are resettled will be
given the support including up to five
years of training with the help of
integration accommodation healthcare so
that they can resettle and thrive
this agreement fully complies with all
international and national law
and as part of this groundbreaking
agreement the uk is making a substantial
investment in the economic development
of rwanda
this will support programs to improve
the lives of people in rwanda and
develop the country the economy job
prospects and opportunities in addition
the uk will provide funding and
expertise to implement this agreement
as i have said many many times
this is a global issue
with many countries struggling to
address the challenges and the causes
and there is no single or simple
solution
this agreement illustrates that we can
no longer accept the status quo
people are dying and the global
migration crisis requires new ways
to find new partnerships and to find new
solutions
it will also deal a major blow to the
evil people smugglers
we know that this will not be easy we
know that we will face challenges along
the way but together with the
nationality and borders bill and the new
plan for immigration the uk will support
those fleeing oppression and persecution
and tyranny through safe and legal
routes while controlling our borders and
deterring illegal entry
our world leading migration and economic
development partnership is a global
first and it'll change the way we
collectively tackle illegal migration
through new innovative and world-leading
solutions thank you
[Applause]
you